Hey, Will, good to see you. Oh, hey. Look, I brought a friend today. His name's Sean. Hey. Oh, hi. Hey, guys. Yeah.
嘿，威尔，很高兴见到你。哦，嘿。听着，我今天带了个朋友来。他叫肖恩。嘿。哦，嗨。嘿，伙计们。对。
Sean, Jason kind of looks like he's, like, on the East Coast. Like, he's in Vermont or something, doesn't he? He does. I thought the trees in his window. It's so pretty. You know, that is something somebody asked me the other day about, well, why don't we have a video component to this? Right.
肖恩，杰森看起来有点像在东海岸。比如，他好像在佛蒙特州或者什么地方，对吧？确实是。我看到他窗户周围的树。太漂亮了。你知道，前几天有人问我这件事，就是，为什么我们不做个视频连线呢？对吧。
And I said, well, we thought about that. But then we thought, well, maybe we might not book people quite as easily because they might think, oh, I'm going to be on cameras and they don't want to get all made up. Yeah. Let's just do voices. Yeah. Yeah. Smartness.
我说，嗯，我们考虑过。但后来我们觉得，嗯，也许我们不会那么容易约到嘉宾，因为他们可能会想，哦，我要上镜头了，他们不想精心打扮。对。我们就只用声音吧。对。对。太聪明了。
You don't have to look pretty. You just have to sound pretty. Why? Welcome to the Pretty Pretty Tones. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
你不需要长得好看。你只需要声音好听。为什么？欢迎来到“美妙之声”。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Yeah.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。对。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Let's do our next voice. Let's. I want to ask you something. Last night, Scotty and I were sitting on the couch and we watched TV. And.
对。对。对。我们来听听下一个声音。让我们。我想问你个事。昨晚，斯科蒂和我坐在沙发上看电视。然后。
Huh. Whoa. Hang on a second. Let me just write this down. You guys were watching from the couch watching TV last night. I want to mark the date. Oh, hang on. I marked it yesterday and the day before that.
哈。哇。等一下。让我把它记下来。你们昨晚坐在沙发上看电视。我想记下这个日期。哦，等等。我昨天和前天都记下了。
Yeah. And the day before that. That's our class time. Oh, there you go. And we're sitting there watching, and we're watching either, you know, Flora, Bama, Shor or a million dollar listing or project runway. Do you guys feel yourselves getting smarter? Yeah, about a minute.
对。还有前天。那是我们的上课时间。哦，原来如此。我们坐在那里看，看什么佛罗里达州巴马海岸（Flora Bama Shore）还是百万美元挂牌（Million Dollar Listing）或者天桥骄子（Project Runway）。你们觉得自己变聪明了吗？对，大约一分钟。
And I have to stop and ask a lot of questions because I'm very curious. He got so upset with me. He's like, he turned to me and he's like, don't ask me to stop recording, like stop the TV again. We were in the middle. He gets so angry 10 minutes later. He stopped.
我不得不停下来问很多问题，因为我太好奇了。他对我生了好大的气。他转过身来对我说，别让我停下来录音，就像再次暂停电视一样。我们在中间。他10分钟后就生气了。他停了下来。
Hang on. I just need to, as people say unpack this, I don't like using that term just cause. It's kind of fun. Everybody uses it. It's the same with like, you see what I did there? Shut up. So you're going to unpack this.
等等。正如人们所说，我需要“解构”一下，我其实不太喜欢用这个词，只是……挺有意思的。每个人都在用。就像那个，你懂我的意思吗？闭嘴。所以你要解构这个。
So here, let me just say this. So you're not just, you're not happening upon these Florida, Obama shores or whatever it is. You're DVRing these things. Oh, for sure. Okay. Yeah.
所以，让我这么说吧。所以你不是偶然看到这些《佛罗里达巴马海岸》或者别的什么。你们是在用硬盘录像机（DVR）录下来。哦，肯定的。好吧。对。
Oh, for sure. Well, you know, we all have a mutual friend that goes one step further and we'll pause just, I'm sure that there's no paint left on that button, but she also has a laser pointer. For the bachelor and bachelorette. So once it's paused and mystery guest knows what the hell I'm talking about.
哦，肯定的。你知道，我们有个共同的朋友，她更进一步，会按下暂停——我敢肯定那个按钮上的漆都被磨光了——而且她还有个激光笔。为了看《单身汉》和《单身女郎》。所以一旦暂停了，神秘嘉宾就知道我在说什么鬼话了。
Once it's paused, the laser pointer goes up, things are circled, things are pointed out. I love that. Help assist with the comments or really mostly questions. Sean, you like that. I love that. That's how you watch TV. Do you watch TV more for the questions?
一旦暂停，激光笔就拿出来了，圈出重点，指出细节。我太喜欢了。这有助于发表评论，或者其实主要是提出问题。肖恩，你喜欢这个。我太喜欢了。这就是你看电视的方式吗？你看电视更多是为了提问吗？
Is that your big, are you just in it for the questions? Yeah, for sure. No, I love that. I love that laser pointer thing. Oh, I know who that is. Okay, got it. That has been a guest. Yes.
这就是你的大招吗，你就是为了问题而看的？对，肯定的。不，我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个激光笔。哦，我知道那是谁了。好吧，明白了。那曾是个嘉宾。是的。
Yeah. Okay, we'll let listener figure that out. But meanwhile, meanwhile, gang, we got a queen on the show today. Oh yeah? Yeah, she's a queen of movies, the queen of kindness, professionalism, real estate, hospitality and friendship.
对。好吧，我们让听众自己去猜吧。但与此同时，与此同时，各位，我们今天节目来了一位女王。哦是吗？对，她是电影女王、善良女王、专业精神女王、房地产、热情好客和友谊女王。
Oh, she lived her first 12 years in Germany and Austria, spoke only German, ate only schnitzel and wore only braids. She then came to the stage, she made some movies, won some awards, a lot of them. She won an Oscar, a Globe, couple sags, three critics choice awards, three more, she'll tie our net and time named her most influential.
哦，她头12年在德国和奥地利度过，只说德语，只吃炸肉排，只梳辫子。后来她登上了舞台，拍了一些电影，赢得了一些奖项，很多很多。她赢得了奥斯卡奖、金球奖、几个演员工会奖、三个评论家选择奖，再拿三个，她就能追平我们的纪录了，而且《时代》杂志还评选她为最具影响力人物。
People named her most beautiful. Louie and Lila call her mom. We call her a great friend for saying yes to smart listen. Listener, you call her the one and only Sandra Bullock. Sandy. Oh, look at, she held that flag up though. Are your arms killing you? You guys need to land the plane.
人们称她为最美丽的人。路易和莱拉叫她妈妈。我们称她为伟大的朋友，因为她答应了“聪明倾听”。听众朋友们，你们叫她独一无二的桑德拉·布洛克。桑迪。哦，看，她把那面旗子举起来了。你的胳膊酸死了吗？你们该降落了。
Who would have gotten a C stand for you in there somewhere? My boot was the C stand. They brought one in, I didn't realize you guys would be in this holding pattern over LAX. Well, you're in a mess of trouble with it, all the different locals that you're not in right now. Yeah, you can't hold, you can't Hollywood your own stand, your own flag.
谁会在那儿给你准备个C型灯架（C-stand）？我的靴子就是C型灯架。他们拿了一个进来，我没意识到你们会在洛杉矶国际机场（LAX）上空盘旋。好吧，你惹上大麻烦了，因为你现在不在那些不同的地方。对，你不能滞空，你不能把自己的站位、自己的旗子好莱坞化。
Sorry. How's the junket going? Listener, she's at a junket. She's promoting- You're literally at a junket. I'm at a junket. She's promoting the- Hi guys. Well, first of all, hello. Hi. Hi.
抱歉。宣传采访（junket）进行得怎么样？听众朋友们，她正在参加宣传采访。她在宣传——你字面意思就是在参加宣传采访。我在参加宣传采访。她在宣传——大家好。好吧，首先，你好。嗨。嗨。
Yeah, Jason, hi, let us say hi. Jason, I have Amanda as my lifeline on the phone, so should you give me any problems? You have her on speaker right now? No, she's on my phone and she's sitting by, standing by with her phone just in case I should need her. In case you get some really probing question from us incredible journalists.
对，杰森，嗨，让我们打个招呼。杰森，我让阿曼达作为我的场外求助电话，所以你要是敢给我出难题——你现在开着免提吗？没有，她在我的手机上，她正拿着手机随时待命，以防我需要她。以防我们这些伟大的记者问你什么深入的探究性问题。
I like a probe. Yeah, we got it, thank you for the interview. You knew that. We got the quote, there it is. Hey, so how's the junket going forward, the unforgivable, which looks incredible? Yes. It's so far so good.
我喜欢探究。对，我们收到了，谢谢你的采访。你知道的。我们拿到原话了，就是这样。嘿，那么关于电影《不可饶恕》（The Unforgivable）的宣传采访进展如何？这电影看起来太棒了。是的。到目前为止一切顺利。
I mean, I haven't spoken to anyone- Are you in the middle of it? Yeah, at the beginning of it. So I just have to relearn how to speak to adults and people that I don't know other than- Wrong place. The living under my house and your wife and your children. That's all I've seen in two years.
我是说，我还没跟任何人——你正在进行中吗？对，刚开始。所以我必须重新学习如何与成年人以及我不认识的人说话，除了——走错地方了。住在我屋子底下的那些人，还有你的妻子和孩子。这两年我见过的就只有这些。
Well, there's no adults here and you know how the junkets go. There's very few adults there in a good way. Wait, I wanna ask you something right off the bat because this movie looks good and everything. How do you go about choosing what seems to be always the right project? That's not true. That's stuff.
好吧，这里没有成年人，你也知道宣传采访是怎么回事。那里的成年人很少，以一种好的方式来说。等等，我一开场就想问你个问题，因为这部电影看起来很不错之类的。你是如何挑选那些似乎总是正确的项目的？那不是真的。都是瞎扯。
But it's, from this side, it always does. You know, like, I don't know. This came to me and when I read it, it reminded me of things that I learned when I was on my journey with my daughter to find my daughter. And it just is the more I researched, the more I learned about-
但从这边看，总是这样。你知道，就像，我不知道。这个剧本送到我手上时，当我读到它，它让我想起了一些事情，那是我在带着女儿寻找女儿的旅程中学到的。这只是，我研究得越多，我对——有了更多了解。
That's a- Go ahead and go through. Go ahead and go through. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I'm blowing some leaves. Obviously they ordered some food where I was and it's not for me. You go ahead and go that way. Thank you so much.
这是一个——继续说吧。继续说。对，对，对。我在吹树叶。显然他们在我的地方订了食物，那不是给我的。你朝那边走吧。非常感谢。
What's on there? There's a guy rolling it. Jason, guess what's on there? It's a charcuterie. Oh my God. Nothing made me happier than setting up the charcuterie when Jason would come because he loved his meats and I would roll them out in the cheeses.
上面是什么？有个家伙在推着车。杰森，你猜上面有什么？是熟食拼盘。天哪。没有什么比杰森来的时候摆好熟食拼盘更让我高兴的了，因为他喜欢吃肉，我会把肉和奶酪卷起来。
In cheeses, meats and cheeses. And then he went vegan. Just as we're talking to, as we're talking to Sandy, somebody behind her rolled out right behind her. It's a huge plate. People can't see that. Hotel catering cart. Yeah, no, nobody can put together a charcuterie,
奶酪，肉和奶酪。然后他变成了纯素食者。就在我们和桑迪说话的时候，她身后有人推着车从她后面经过。那是一个巨大的盘子。人们看不到那个。酒店餐饮推车。对，不，没有人能像你一样摆出一盘熟食。
slab of wood like you. It's kind of sweet, right? It's great. It's kind of sweet. That's what you brought back from Germany and Austria. The meat, you know, you're kind of right? Yeah. Because you eat a lot of meats for breakfast,
木板，对吧？挺甜的，对吧？太棒了。挺甜的。那是你从德国和奥地利带回来的。肉，你知道，你说得对吗？对。因为你早餐吃很多肉，
a lot of sliced meats. Bratwurst. Bratwurst and Brezen. Those European breakfast buffets and you've got like all this stuff for everybody and then for the- I don't know where you were where there were buffets. You've never been to a buffet?
很多切片肉。德国 bratwurst 香肠。德国 bratwurst 香肠和蝴蝶面包（Brezen）。那些欧洲早餐自助餐，你给每个人准备了所有这些东西，然后为了——我不知道你在哪里见过自助餐。你从来没去过自助餐吗？
In Europe? We just had it at home. We just had it at home. My aunt in Germany. I like a European breakfast buffet. Come on, are you kidding? I'd never had a buffet there. Listen, let me just say this.
在欧洲？我们只是在家里吃。我们只是在家里吃。我在德国的阿姨。我喜欢欧洲早餐自助餐。拜托，你在开玩笑吗？我从来没在那里吃过自助餐。听着，让我这么说吧。
I listen, I'm relatable to the people to our listeners. They get it. They get me, I live a very relatable life. Hey, before we leave Austria, do you remember anything from Austria or Germany that's fond? I didn't know that. My family's still there.
听着，我对我们的听众来说是很接地气的。他们懂。他们懂我，我过着非常接地气的生活。嘿，在我们离开奥地利之前，你还记得奥地利或德国的什么美好回忆吗？我不知道。我的家人还在那里。
My whole side of my, the cousins that I was raised with, my aunt and uncle, the house that we grew up in. It's all there. Do you still know how to speak German? Yeah, I speak German. Wait, wait, how about, how about it's a pleasure to be with you today?
我所有的，和我一起长大的表亲，我的阿姨和叔叔，我们长大的房子。都在那儿。你现在还懂德语吗？对，我会说德语。等等，等等，那句“很高兴今天能和你在一起”怎么说？
But it's not good for me. Come on. It's not good for me. It doesn't make me happy that I'm here with you. I think it's the funniest- I love it. language. I love it so much.
但这对我可不好。拜托。这对我可不好。能和你在一起并不让我高兴。我觉得这是最有趣的——语言。我太喜欢了。
I know there's nothing, you can try to soften it to make it more appealing. Say something passionate. Say something passionate in German. Like is dein Arschloch. You know what she just said, Jason? She said she'd like to build a bunker under her house and lock you in it for two years.
我知道没有什么，你可以试着把它说得委婉一点，让它听起来更有吸引力。说点充满激情的话。用德语说点充满激情的话。比如 deine Arschloch（你这个混蛋）。你知道她刚才说什么吗，杰森？她说她想在她的房子下面建一个掩体，把你锁在里面两年。
Wow, it's a few words. I said you are an asshole. Now, while you were over there, mom was singing in the opera guys, okay? She was an opera singer. And did you, can you sing? No. No.
哇，就几个词。我说你是个混蛋。好了，你在那边的时候，妈妈在歌剧里唱歌，对吧？她是个歌剧演员。你会唱歌吗？不会。不会。
At all. Because Amanda, who's father is a singer, she can't sing. I think it skips a generation. Lila, my daughter, has pipes like you would not. So it skipped me and landed on Lila. But both my parents were opera singers and then subsequently voice teachers. And I have no, we're really musical in the household.
一点也不会。因为阿曼达，她的父亲是个歌手，她也不会唱歌。我想这会隔代遗传。我的女儿莱拉，有着你想象不到的好嗓子。所以它跳过了我，落在了莱拉身上。但我父母都是歌剧演员，后来又成了声乐老师。而我没有，我们家里真的很有音乐氛围。
We're just love music, dance, all that kind of stuff. But I just- Did you learn operas when you were younger? Did you- I was in them. I can hum any opera. I was in, you know, there's always a dirty child in every opera.
我们就是热爱音乐、舞蹈以及所有这类东西。但我只是——你小时候学过歌剧吗？你——我参演过。我能哼唱任何歌剧。我演过，你知道，每个歌剧里都有一个肮脏的小孩。
And I was usually the dirty child, the extras. A babysitting service for my mother. Do you know any of the music from promises, promises? Have you ever heard of this? Sure don't. Sure don't. I don't know if it's an opera. Is that a good one?
我通常就是那个肮脏的小孩，群演。我母亲的临时托儿所。你知道音乐剧《承诺，承诺》（Promises, Promises）里的任何音乐吗？你听说过这个吗？当然没有。当然没有。我不知道这算不算歌剧。那是一部好剧吗？
That's Sean's fastball. Doesn't really feel like an opera that was born out of the classics. Sean? Not even close. Now, when you were over there and you're following mom around as the dirty kid, did you have dreams of Hollywood and acting
那是肖恩的拿手好戏。听起来可不像是从古典乐中诞生的歌剧。肖恩？差得远呢。现在，当你在那边，作为那个脏兮兮的小孩跟着妈妈到处跑时，你对好莱坞和表演有什么梦想吗，
or was that just something that happened once you came over on the, on the stewardship? I think I was always a hand bone, you know? I was always writing scripts and making the neighbors, you know, I think it was a way to meet guys. I mean, we had many boys in the neighborhood. So I was like, I'll write a script and they'll have to be in it.
还是说那只是你来到美国（on the stewardship - 译者注：此处台词口误/听力模糊，按语境处理）之后自然发生的事？我想我一直是个小戏精（hand bone - 俚语/口误，意指爱表现的人），你知道的？我总是写剧本，让邻居们，你知道的，我想这是一种结识男孩的方法。我的意思是，我们街区有很多男孩。所以我当时想，我写个剧本，他们就得参演。
And they all turned out like me. They all turned out like me. This is once you were in the States or still in Germany? This is in the States. In Germany, there, well, the schools in Germany are incredibly artistic. I went to a Waldorf school.
结果他们都变得像我一样。他们都变得像我一样。这是在你到了美国之后还是还在德国？这是在美国。在德国，嗯，德国的学校非常有艺术气息。我上的是华德福学校（Waldorf school）。
So they have a, the arts were just very prevalent. But I didn't at that point. They had a breakfast buffet? They had a meat buffet. It had a big, they had an incredible, it had a school buffet, sorry. Shetty balls. Is that what?
所以他们有，艺术氛围非常浓厚。但当时我还没有。他们有早餐自助餐吗？他们有肉类自助餐。它有一个很大的，他们有一个令人难以置信的，它有一个学校自助餐，对不起。希蒂球（Shetty balls - 梗/误听）。那是什麽？
Shetty, yeah, yeah, yeah. We love the Shetty's. Now, okay, so then it was kind of a way to... Is this really interesting for you, Jason? Because it's funny that you're asking me questions about my life. These are things I can't ask you when we're over the charcoery board.
谢蒂，对，对，对。我们喜欢谢蒂。好了，好吧，所以这有点像是一种方式……杰森，这对你来说真的很有趣吗？因为你问我关于我的生活的问题，这很有趣。这些是我在冷盘餐桌旁时不能问你的事情。
I don't know any of this. Do you really care? I guess who else cares? The listener cares. I could talk you about the opera thing for three hours. Were you in Carmen by any chance? I wasn't, but I could talk to you about yours and Scotty's little lip-syncing
我对这些一无所知。你真的在乎吗？我想还有谁在乎呢？听众在乎。我可以跟你聊三个小时关于歌剧的事。你碰巧演过《卡门》吗？我没有，但我可以跟你聊聊你和斯科蒂的那点假唱
that you guys need to pick up again. Please, dear God. I almost ended in a divorce. I hope they don't. I call that the unforgivable when they do that. What is that? I don't know anything about that. They lip-synced and he'd come up with a cowbell
你们需要重新开始。求求上帝了。我差点就离婚了。我希望他们别这样。当他们那样做时，我称之为不可原谅的行为。那是什么？我对这个一无所知。他们对口型假唱，然后他拿着一个牛铃走过来
and he'd go back down in the little maracas and it was the sweetest. It was so sweet and so special. Thank you, my dear. And funny and so well choreographed. And we almost got you in one and then we couldn't figure it out. I know, but I would have ruined it.
然后他会回到小马拉卡斯去，那真是太美妙了。太甜美了，也太特别了。谢谢你，亲爱的。既搞笑又排练得那么好。我们差点把你弄进去一个，然后我们没搞懂。我知道，不过那样我就把它搞砸了。
I wouldn't have done what you guys, there's just a charm that you guys just, you were so in sync and I would have out of synced it. You're very sweet. Jay, we did a bunch of like silly stupid dumb lip-sync videos. Look it up. It's so good. Yeah, and so good.
我要是像你们那样做肯定做不来，你们之间有一种默契，而我会把这种默契给破坏掉。你太会说话了。杰，我们拍过一堆那种傻乎乎、愚蠢又无聊的对口型视频。去搜搜看吧。真的很棒。对，而且拍得太好了。
This was filmed. This was filmed, yeah. It wasn't in our house. Phone, yeah, in our house. It's stupid, it's stupid. But it kind of blew up and it got like hundreds and hundreds of millions. Did it blow up?
这段被拍下来了。这段被拍下来了，对。不在我们家里。手机，对，在我们家里。这很蠢，真的很蠢。但它有点火了，获得了好几亿的播放量。真的火了吗？
It was crazy. Yeah, it was. This sensation. Otherwise, when did you fit it in between TV viewings? Like, how did you get the time? While we were watching TV. It was in the room with the pocket doors. That's right.
太疯狂了。是的，确实如此。这种感觉。不然的话，你什么时候在看电视的间隙做这个呢？比如，你是怎么抽出时间的？在我们看电视的时候。它就在有推拉门的那个房间里。没错。
That's in the next room over. All right, wait, I want to keep this thing on the rails. So we're in Hollywood and we're approaching employment and dating and all of that stuff. That started in New York. I was East Coast when it started. All right. Wait, wait, wait, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
就在隔壁房间。好吧，等等，我想把这件事拉回正轨。所以我们现在在好莱坞，我们要谈谈工作、约会以及所有这些事情。这一切是从纽约开始的。刚开始的时候我在东海岸。好吧。等等，等等，等等，对不起，对不起，对不起，对不起。
Let's back up. Can you move from Germany to the US? We would go back and forth based on the opera seasons and we lived between Salzburg, as it's said in English, and then Nuremberg. And when my mother would travel, I'd live with my cousins and my grandmother and my aunt and go to German school there.
我们退回一步说。你能从德国搬到美国吗？我们会根据歌剧演出季来回奔波，生活在萨尔茨堡（英语里的说法）和纽伦堡之间。当我母亲去旅行时，我和表亲、祖母以及阿姨一起住，并在那里的德国学校上学。
Okay, so wait, you lived in Salzburg for a while? It's the most beautiful place I've ever lived. It's so beautiful. Well, the land of Mozart. It is, yeah. Wasn't Beethoven born there too, I think, perhaps? No, that was, that's Mozart, Mozart. I get them so confused.
好吧，等等，你曾在萨尔茨堡住过一段时间？那是我住过最美丽的地方。太美了。嗯，莫扎特故乡。是的，确实是。贝多芬好像也是在那里出生的吧，也许？不，那是，那是莫扎特，莫扎特。我总是把他们弄混。
Yeah. I like them both. We're gonna get lots of comments on this, just for like, hey, I wish there was a way to find out, I guess. Yes, and his house is amazing. His house is in a main through fare where they have a lot, like they have the shops built into the old buildings
是的，我两个都喜欢。我们肯定会收到很多关于这个的评论，比如，嘿，我猜要是能找到就好了。是的，他的房子太棒了。他的房子位于一条主干道上，那里有很多店铺，都是建在老建筑里的。
and you go in and the doorways are really tiny and low and it's beautiful. It's really, it's a magical place. All right, so then we're in New York and we're starting to get- Waitressing. We're waitressing and who are your contemporaries at that age? Like, is there somebody that's still going right now
你走进去，门道非常小而且很低，非常美丽。真的，这是一个神奇的地方。好的，然后我们在纽约，我们开始做——端盘子。我们在端盘子，你那个年纪同辈的人都有谁？比如，有没有谁现在还在继续演艺事业的
that you kind of came up with, actor-wise or actress-wise? Well, everyone that was my contemporary was waiting tables with me, so I had no contemporary in New York City. I was a waitress. All right. Well, like, did you battle anybody roles back then that you're still battling today?
无论是演员还是女演员，你有没有想到过什么人？嗯，当时和我同龄的人都和我一起在端盘子，所以在纽约市我没有同龄人。我曾是一名女服务员。好吧。那么，你当时有没有和什么人竞争过角色，而到现在你们还在竞争？
I didn't audition. I was just, I had backstage, I don't know if, is that still around, backstage magazine in New York? I think so, yeah. You know what, have the ads and I would find what was appropriate and I'd hit the ground during the day
我没有去试镜。我只是，我在后台，我不知道，纽约现在还有那个吗，《后台》杂志？我想是的，是的。你知道吗，看那些广告，然后我会找出合适的，白天的时候我就开始行动了
and, you know, there's room full of pervs or something was legit and you either ran or you stayed for, you know, an audition and- Where were you waitressing? Canestells on 19th and Park. It's not there anymore. And how did you like that?
然后，你知道的，那里有一屋子的色狼或者类似情况，这是真的，你要么逃跑，要么留下来参加，你知道的，试镜，然后——你当时在哪里端盘子？19街和公园街的Canestells餐厅。现在已经没有了。你觉得那里怎么样？
How did you like that? Were you any good as a waitress or did you hate it? Well, I was, I started off in coachech and then I was upgraded to hostessing, which I was terrible at because I had to know everyone and really give preference to the special people and I didn't know who was special. And then they moved me to the cocktail lounge
你觉得怎么样？你当服务员做得好吗，还是讨厌这份工作？嗯，我一开始是在长途汽车上，然后被升职为迎宾员，但我做得一塌糊涂，因为我必须认识每个人，还要真正优待那些特殊人物，可我根本不知道谁是特殊人物。接着他们把我调到了鸡尾酒休息室。
where I ruled, I was amazing. I was amazing. Why? Because I gave people shit. Like I wasn't the cute waitress, I was just the smart ass. So I knew what people liked, that I would have it ready for them,
在我管辖的地方，我太厉害了。我简直太厉害了。为什么？因为我给他们找麻烦。就像我不是那个可爱的女服务员，我只是个自作聪明的人。所以我知道人们喜欢什么，我会为他们准备好，
they would bring their clients in, I would really work it for them and then I'd get a great tip because I really treated the clients, you know, in a special way and I could just handle that. Yeah, they get all banged up. They want a saucy, sassy waitress. Lots of banging.
他们会带客户来，我真的会为他们好好服务，然后我会得到很高的小费，因为我真的对客户很好，你知道的，用一种特殊的方式，我完全应付得来。是的，他们总是磕磕碰碰的。他们想要一个风情万种、俏皮的服务员。有很多碰撞。
Yeah, we got it. All right, we got so many good quotes on this. Your publicist must be in a deep sweat right now, just off camera. How far off camera is your publicist with the headphones? 25 feet, but she's been with me for so long, she's just numb to it now. She's just, as long as I've not killed or maimed anyone,
是的，我们听到了。好吧，我们从中得到了好多精彩的名言。你的公关现在一定急得满头大汗，就在镜头外面。你的公关戴着耳机离镜头有多远？25英尺，但她跟我很久了，现在已经麻木了。她只要求只要我没杀人或弄残任何人就行，
she's like, she's fine. All right, so now you're telling me you did not audition for, because I want to know if there wasn't audition for this, I want to know how it went, speed. Oh, audition, but not until I moved to LA. Like I got off, off Broadway things and then somehow did NYU films, little films
她就觉得，她很好。好吧，所以现在你告诉我你没有去试镜，因为我想知道如果没有人为这个试镜的话，我想知道过程怎么样，Speed。哦，试镜过，但直到我搬到洛杉矶才开始。就像我做过外百老汇的东西，然后不知怎么地拍了纽约大学的电影，一些小电影。
and cobbled together a little real and somehow got an agent and then did TV, got some TV gigs and... What'd you get on TV? It was one show I can't remember, but it was with Major Healy. Remember from my dream of Jeannie, he was a vet. Sure I do.
然后凑合着搞了点真实的经历，不知怎么的还找了个经纪人，接着就去演电视了，接了几个电视演出……你演的是什么电视？是一个节目，我记不清了，但里面有马约尔·希利。还记得《我梦见珍妮》里的他吗？他演过一个兽医。我当然记得。
Like it was a weird, I don't even remember, but... Was Major Healy Larry Hagman's friend or was he... Yes, yes. Roger, wasn't it Roger? I don't remember his name. Roger Healy. I thought he was great.
就像那是一个奇怪的，我甚至都不记得了，但是……少校希利是拉里·哈格曼的朋友还是他是……对，对。罗杰，不是罗杰吗？我不记得他的名字了。罗杰·希利。我觉得他棒极了。
Then I moved to LA for work, but it was also a boy. And then I just started auditioning. Yeah, stop right there. Will likes to hear about all the love affairs. You can't just skip over the me. Don't pull your chair in. Let's get into this. Let's dig in, let's dig in.
后来我为了工作搬到了洛杉矶，但其实也是为了一个男生。然后我就开始去试镜了。对，就在这停一下。威尔很喜欢听所有的风流韵事。你不能就这样跳过我这一段。别把椅子拉过来。我们来聊聊这个。深入了解一下，深入了解一下。
So there's a boy. So you moved out to be here with... You moved out with him? Just for summer, I was just gonna be here for two months. That's all the money I had really earned on the last gig. And then I just auditioned and then started getting little tiny things here and there. And then it all fell apart.
所以有个男孩。所以你搬到这里是为了……你跟他一起搬过来的？只是为了夏天，我本来打算在这里呆两个月。那真的是我在上一份工作里赚到的全部积蓄。然后我就去试镜，接着开始断断续续接一些极小的角色。然后这一切就都泡汤了。
Yeah. And then the career went right down the toilet. Yeah, right down the crapper. All right, so, but wait. So you were auditioning. So was there an audition for Speed? Yeah, big time. Okay, I'll just picture you in a folding chair.
对。然后职业生涯就彻底完蛋了。对，简直一塌糊涂。好吧，等一下。所以你在试镜。那么《生死时速》有试镜吗？对，规模很大。好吧，我脑海里浮现出你坐在折叠椅上的样子。
That's exactly what it was. Pretending to be pressing on gas and then break. With a fake steering wheel. No way, fake steering. And sweet Keanu Reeves standing, like really trying to help me and do the scene. And then somehow we landed on the floor in a heap, you know, from the scene.
完全就是这样。假装踩油门然后踩刹车。还用一个假的方向盘。没门，假方向盘。还有甜美的基努·里维斯站在那里，真的很努力地帮我入戏。然后不知怎么的，我们在戏里一堆人摔倒在地板上，你知道的。
And I was all schmitzing and flop sweaty and it was... Wait, was he in there with you? Yeah. Oh my God. So it was kind of the camera's turning too. I was sweating so badly. And that shit is so weird. Isn't that so weird doing that?
我当时又紧张又狼狈，直冒虚汗，然后……等等，他那时候也跟你在一起吗？对啊。天哪。所以镜头也在转动。我汗流浃背。那种感觉太诡异了。做那种事是不是超级诡异？
It's so odd. Will, I had to do that with Amy, with Polar. For, we were gonna do a movie together. And I remember we auditioned together and I feel like, I don't think we had to kiss in it, but I remember there was like... Wait, not heartbreak. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
太奇怪了。威尔，我和艾米、还有波拉一起合作过。我们本来要一起拍一部电影。我记得我们一起去试镜，我觉得，虽然我们在里面好像不用接吻，但我记得当时有那种……等等，不是心碎。对，对，对。
Really? Yeah. And we are in there in the room together. I just remember it being super hot and sweaty. Like, this is weird auditioning with a friend. I mean, that's weird. Like having to audition in general, but intimately pretend like you are with a friend.
真的吗？是的。我们当时一起在房间里。我只记得里面超级热，全是汗。就觉得，和朋友一起试镜好奇怪。我是说，这本身就很奇怪。总归得去试镜，但还要装作和朋友很亲密的样子。
With your buddy's wife. I can't, can't. Well, like, have you, I'm sure you've had to have a romantic, have you ever had to have a friend play your husband or a boyfriend in a film? No. Good.
你朋友的妻子。我不行、不行。那个，比如说你是否——我确信你一定有过敕事，你曾经让柔情过的——你曾经让柔情的朋友在电影里扮演你的丈夠还是男油？没有。好的。
Like if I had to fight with you? Yes, I could do that. Sandy, if you and Jason had to do this like... This is gonna hurt my feelings. Epic love story. No, no, no. I would ask Amanda to come in. I'd put a wig on her and let you guys go at it.
就像如果我必须跟你打架？是的，我可以做到。桑迪，如果你和杰森必须做这个，就像……这会伤了我的心。史诗般的爱情故事。不，不，不。我会请阿曼达进来。我会给她戴上假发，让你们两个大打出手。
And then I would be the part where I broke out it. Cause I feel that it's wrong. I would feel so wrong. I couldn't. Because you gotta sell it. But it's not real. Are you worried that if you got in that thing and you guys had to have this love thing
然后我会成为打破这一切的那个人。因为我觉得这是错的。我会觉得太不对劲了。我做不到。因为你得去迎合它。但这不是真的。你是否担心如果你进入了那种状态，你们不得不假装有这种恋爱关系
and kiss each other and look at each other. Are you worried you'd fall in love with Jason? Are you worried you'd fall in love with Jason? It's, there's a high risk. It's tough. Sandy, what if it was a love scene between me and you? That I would nail it. I would nail it.
然后互相亲吻，看着对方。你担心自己会爱上杰森吗？你担心自己会爱上杰森吗？这，风险很高。这很难。桑迪，如果那是我和你之间的爱情戏呢？我会做好的。我会做好的。
I would be so good. Sean, I would be so good. You would question all of your decisions in life. I'm questioning them right now. You're claiming that you're claiming that Sean would question everything after it. He would question everything. He wouldn't change it.
我会表现得非常出色。肖恩，我会表现得非常出色。你会质疑你人生中的所有决定。我现在就在质疑它们。你声称你声称肖恩之后会质疑一切。他会质疑一切。他不会改变它。
I didn't say he would change it. But it would confuse me. It would confuse me. This is actually really. Confusing feelings. It's nice. What about, well, now you've done both. What about us?
我没说他会改变它。但这会让我糊涂。这会让我糊涂。这其实真的很令人困惑。这感觉很奇妙。那好吧，现在你两边都体验过了。那我们呢？
Yeah. Well, that's good. And that's going to be what it is. That's going to be fireworks. That is everything that nothing else was. And that became. Well, you don't need to give her the hot eyes. What are you talking about?
是的。好吧，这很好。事情就会是这样。那将会是烟花绽放。那是其他一切所不具备的一切。而这成为了现实。好吧，你不需要用那种火辣的眼神看着她。你在说什么呢？
What are you doing hot eyes? You guys are so small. Come in closer. Let me see the hot eyes. Well, just lean in for a second. Lean in. Y'all just gotta pretend there's a fire in the room. Yeah, there we go.
你们在干什么，热眼？你们几个太小了。靠近点。让我看看热眼。好吧，靠近一会儿就行。靠近点。你们只需要假装房间里着火了。对，就这样。
Okay, fire in the room. Tons of smoke in the room. That's so gross. Jesus. Is that in your eyes? Because you look tired. Jesus. You know what?
好吧，房间里起火了。房间里全是烟。太恶心了。天哪。进你眼睛里了吗？因为你看上去很累。天哪。你知道吗？
I got that today. Do I really look tired? I'm joking. I'm just picking up on you. I know. I know. And we will be right back. And now back to the show.
我今天也收到了。我看起来真的很累吗？我在开玩笑。我只是在逗你。我知道。我知道。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。
I want to ask something, Jay. I want to ask something about the speed. It's called the speed. It's the speed. The speed. So obviously that's the movie. Everybody references that kind of gave you your start. It did, yeah.
我想问个问题，杰伊。我想问一个关于《生死时速》的问题。电影名字就叫《生死时速》。就是《生死时速》。所以显然那是这部电影。每个人都提到那部电影可以说是你的起点。确实是的，没错。
Yeah, for sure. See, I feel like you were a big star before that. I know me too. Am I wrong about that? Like while you were sleeping was huge. I auditioned for that. But that was after. That was after.
是的，确实如此。你看，我觉得在那之前你就是个大明星了。我知道，我也是。我弄错了吗？比如《While You Were Sleeping》超级火。我去试镜过那个。但那是后来的事了。那是后来的事。
Oh, after it. Okay. And so while you were making the speed, did you know like that classic question, did you know like in the moment where you're like, this is fucking awesome. People are going to go crazy. No, we were on a bus.
哦，追上它了。好吧。所以当你在拍《生死时速》的时候，你知道吗，就像那个经典的问题，当下的那种感觉，你会不会觉得“这太他妈棒了，人们一定会为之疯狂的”？不，我们当时在一辆公车上。
There was a bomb on the bus. We were on the, you know, doing circles at the airport in an unused part of the airport. Were you at LAX? Did you guys shoot that at LAX? We did. And then we were on the 105, that strip right before LAX. That hadn't been opened yet.
公交车上有炸弹。我们在机场里，你知道的，在机场一个没用过的区域绕圈。你们在洛杉矶国际机场吗？你们是在洛杉矶国际机场拍的那个吗？是的。然后我们在105号州际公路上，就在洛杉矶国际机场前面还没开通的那段路拍的。
Right. And we was just, I mean, the Keanu was crazy famous. And then there was me and the crew on the bus. And we just kind of all hung out together. It was, you know, we were the bomb on the bus movie. It was Yandabot, who was a cinematographer. So you were not a star yet. So Keanu had, it was a Keanu Reeves above the title.
对啊。我们当时就，我的意思是，基努红得发紫。然后我和剧组人员都在大巴上。我们就这样聚在一起。你知道的，我们就是《生死时速》电影里的红人。那是扬达博特，他是摄影师。所以你当时还不是明星。所以基努，他是片名上面的基努·里维斯。
Keanu Reeves. Absolutely, Keanu Reeves. And then a bus flying in the background. And a bus. Like the bus was above the title too. And there was a stunt driver in my dress in a wiglet. No. Behind the wheel of, yes.
基努·里维斯。绝对是基努·里维斯。然后背景里有一辆飞驰的公交车。还有一辆公交车。就像公交车也在标题上方一样。还有一个特技演员穿着我的裙子，戴着一个小假发。没有。在……是的，方向盘后面。
He was about 220 in that little slip dress and a little bang. So if you look closely, I think they've somehow inserted me in some places, but it's just, it should have been all Keanu and all bus. There's no Sandy was needed. Wow. Now, all right.
他当时穿着那件小吊带裙，留着齐刘海，体重大概有220磅。所以如果你仔细看，我觉得他们在某些地方不知怎么把我合成进去了，但其实，那本该完全是基努和那辆公交车的戏份。根本不需要桑迪。哇哦。好吧，行吧。
So that sounds like a fairly manageable, somewhat easy shoot. In comparison to, let's go all the way forward into, let's say gravity, where there's tons of green screen. You got to pretend that you're seeing everything. And it was just stunningly well done by you and them. Martha Graham. Everything was Martha Graham.
听起来这是一场相当好对付、比较轻松的拍摄。相比之下，让我们快进到比如《地心引力》，那里有大量的绿幕。你得假装自己能看到一切。你和他们把这部作品完成得简直惊艳绝伦。玛莎·葛兰姆。一切都是玛莎·葛兰姆式的。
Was that, now, which is easier? Working with a bus that you can see and feel or green screen? Well, the hard part about the bus was, I would be up in the front seat driving and there would be some guy in the back pretending to be someone else actually maneuvering the bus as they're plowing into things.
那个，现在哪个更容易？是跟一辆你能看到、摸到的公交车合作，还是跟绿幕？嗯，公交车难的地方在于，我会坐在前排开车，后面会有个人假装成别人，在撞击东西的同时实际操控着公交车。
So I had absolutely no control over the bus. So that was, that was freaky. I've done something like that before. Very scary. You've done that before, Jay? Yeah, I had to like drive into oncoming traffic and they built a car where the guy up on the roof of the car, they had a cage up there.
所以对这辆公交车我完全无法控制。所以那真是，太吓人了。我以前也经历过类似的事。非常吓人。你以前也经历过那种事吗，杰？是的，我不得不把车开向迎面驶来的车流，他们造了一辆车，那家伙坐在车顶上，上面还有个笼子。
Yeah, we had that too. Right, so he's actually driving and I'm down in the driver's seat and the camera's behind me in the back seat and it looks like I'm driving but the guy on the roof is actually driving and we're driving 60 miles an hour into oncoming traffic on a freeway.
对，我们当时也那样。对吧，所以实际上是他在开，我坐在驾驶座上，摄像机在我后面的后座上，看起来像是我在开车，但其实车顶上的那个人在开车，我们在高速公路上以每小时60英里的速度逆行。
That's all timed out where I go left, the other car goes right, but I'm not doing the driving. So I'm, I have to just trust that this guy's gonna be on it. Otherwise, I have a head on collision 30 times, you know. I gotta go back and rewatch a little house in the prairie. I don't remember. Well, yeah.
时间全都是算好的，我往左走，另一辆车往右走，但我又不是开车的人。所以，我只能相信这家伙能把控好。不然的话，你知道的，我得迎面相撞30次。我得回去重温一下《草原小屋》。我不记得了。好吧，是的。
Sean, that's how you and Scotty, when you go to Chin Chin twice and you get Scotty's on the roof, right? Do you mean Chin Chin, the restaurant? Yeah, you know that. That has that, the chicken salad with the extra crunchies on top. That's right, we eat it so often
肖恩，你和斯科特不就是这样吗，你们去两次Chin Chin，然后去斯科特屋顶的那次，对吧？你是说Chin Chin那家餐厅吗？对，你知道的。就是那个有鸡肉沙拉，上面加了额外脆皮的那个。没错，我们经常吃它
that Scotty framed it as double chins. Yeah, that's what you mean. So, there you go. But wait, wait, wait, wait, finish what you're gonna say about gravity because gravity's one of my favorite movies of all time and you were amazing in it and you won the Oscar and I presented you with the People's Choice Award.
卡兰把厄露兵肉块卡捏成了双字额。是的，你指的就是那个。所以，就是这样。但是等等，把你刚才要说的关于《地必引》的话讲完，因为《地必引》是我最喜爱的电影之一，你在里面表现得太棒了，还赢了奥斯卡，而我还颁给你过人民选择奖。
I didn't, I didn't. You didn't win the Oscar. Let me finish. You didn't win the Oscar for that, but you were nominated for it. Yeah, yeah. She won for blindside. That's right.
我没有，我没有。你没凭那个拿到奥斯卡。让我说完。你没凭那个拿到奥斯卡，但你获得了提名。对，对。她凭《弱点》拿了奖。没错。
We're gonna get to that. But so, so, so we're on, so we're on the spaceship. So we're on the spaceship. So we're in space. That's a green. We're on the rocket here and someone says, so when you went to space, how was it to film? And we were in Alfonso and I were like,
我们马上会讲到那个。但所以，所以，所以我们在，所以我们在飞船上。所以我们在飞船上。所以我们在太空中。那是绿色的。我们坐在这里的火箭上，然后有人问，所以当你去太空时，拍摄感觉怎么样？我和阿方索当时就觉得，
we weren't in space. Oh boy. You know what, it was a really profound time for me in that I was going through some things and I then was on this journey with the great Alfonso Cuaron where it was just me. And Clooney banging on the window trying to get in. Clooney trying to get in.
我们当时不在太空中。天哪。你知道吗，对我来说那是一段非常深刻的时期，我经历了一些事情，然后我和伟大的阿方索·卡隆踏上了这段旅程，只有我一个人。还有克鲁尼在窗户上敲门想进来。克鲁尼想进来。
Clooney's always trying to get in. Another quote. And then I had to cut him loose and let him die so I could have a screen time. It just was, it was amazing because everything that I did up to that point, like in my childhood with dance and music and counting and all the things musically that happened and physically that happened
克鲁尼总想进来。又是一句引用。然后我不得不甩掉他，让他死，这样我才能有出镜时间。这实在是太棒了，因为我之前所做的一切，比如我童年时期的舞蹈、音乐、数拍子，以及所有在音乐上和身体上发生的事情
in my life, incorporating music came into play in order to do this. Cause I'd either be on a bicycle seat with one leg strapped to it and the rest of my body. So I could move in slow mode. I think you guys are watching me. It's like Martha Graham. So I had to, they said this point here is this is Soyuz.
在我的人生中，为了做到这一点，音乐发挥了作用。因为我要么是坐在自行车鞍座上，一条腿绑在上面，身体的其他部分……这样我就可以慢动作移动了。我想你们都在看着我。这就像玛莎·格雷厄姆。所以我不得不这样做，他们说这里的这个点就是联盟号。
This is George. This is so you have 10 seconds to get from here to there. Is this contraption move? So I had to move my body like I was swimming in slow motion while my voice got to move normally. So it was isolating. It was beautiful. I saw the making of it.
这是乔治。这是为了让你有10秒钟的时间从这里走到那里。这个奇奇怪怪的装置在动吗？所以我不得不移动我的身体，就像我在慢动作中游泳一样，而我的声音却在正常移动。所以这很孤立。这很美。我看到了它的制作过程。
It was incredible. It's really emotional. Like, and you have, you have Chivo who is an extraordinary cinematographer just trying to figure out technology as we were shooting basically. And we didn't know what it was. We had two previews and they were not great.
这太不可思议了。这真的很感人。而且，你还有奇沃，他是一个非凡的摄影师，基本上就在我们拍摄的时候试图弄清楚技术。我们当时都不知道那是什么。我们有两个试映会，效果都不是很好。
Really? Because the effects weren't in, the music wasn't in. You saw, you know, lines and it just felt, oh my God. I'm coming out of, I thought there's a rebirth for me. I felt good. Life was on the uptick and then I saw the preview and I was like, oh my God, this is going to tank. I just, I'm just going to go back home with my baby
真的吗？因为特效还没做进去，音乐也没放进去。你看到的全是线条，然后就会觉得，哦，天哪。我走出来了，我以为对我来说是一次重获新生。我感觉很好。生活正在好转，然后我看了试映会，我想，哦，天哪，这票房要砸了。我只想，我只想带着我的宝贝回家，
and we're just going to stay put. And how was the early stuff? Like, as it was approaching the release date listener, there's a thing called tracking where you can sort of like get a sort of like a hint as to how the movie's going to perform based on how much the public is aware of it. Was that all stuff good?
然后我们就在那儿待着不出去了。那早期的反响怎么样？就像快要上映的时候，听众朋友们，有一种东西叫试映票房追踪，你可以通过它大致了解公众对电影的了解程度，从而预估电影的票房表现。那些数据都很好吗？
No, I honestly don't know because I didn't get the sense that we had, I mean, I had the most profound experience of my career, just the personal life mixed with the kindest people being in England, just, you know, like, it was just beautiful, all things kind of helped healing. And then not until we went to the Venice Film Festival, which was sort of a blur to begin with,
不，老实说我不知道，因为我没有那种感觉，我的意思是，我有我职业生涯中最深刻的体验，只是个人生活与在英国遇到的最善良的人们交织在一起，你知道的，这真的很美好，所有这一切都有助于疗愈。直到我们去威尼斯电影节，那一开始就像是一场模糊的梦，
fittings in your hair and not have to get on a boat, what I have to look over my shoulder, what I have to, I'm not good at any of that. I just want to implode and hide in a corner. Jason, you know, I don't leave the house. Which is so surprising to me because you're incredibly charismatic and friendly. With people I feel safe with.
头发上弄着造型，不用上船，我还要回头看吗，我还要，我不擅长所有这些。我只想自我毁灭，躲在一个角落里。贾森，你知道的，我都不出门。这让我感到很惊讶，因为你非常有魅力，也很友好。对那些让我感到安全的人。
But you also, but you know how to make people who you don't know and they don't, you, you know how to make them feel safe. Like you have incredible people skills. But that's with human beings. That's with people. I don't want a camera point. I don't want to be looked at that way.
但你也会，但你知道怎么让那些你不认识的人——他们也不认识你——让他们感到安全。就像你有难以置信的人际交往能力。但那是针对人类的。那是针对人们的。我不想有镜头对准我。我不想以那种方式被注视。
And I don't. Like dissected, yeah. Don't tell her what she's good at. She's telling you. Thank you, well, thank you. Yeah, let hers be. Good, no, thank you, well. No, please don't.
我也不想。像被解剖一样，是的。别告诉她她擅长什么。她自己会说。谢谢，好吧，谢谢。是的，让她自己说吧。好，不，谢谢，好吧。不，请不要。
Do you connect with Sean at all? Do you feel any connection? Because he feels like a camera, like he's like a robot, right? No, look at him. He's just walking joy. Sean is just walking joy. Thank you.
你跟肖恩有任何共鸣吗？你感觉到有什么联系吗？因为他感觉像个镜头，就像个机器人，对吧？不，看看他。他简直就是行走的快乐。肖恩就是行走的快乐。谢谢。
I didn't know Sandy other than our love for each other. I didn't know how much we had in common with the music and the opera and the. No, here we go. Five, six, seven, eight. Ba, na, na, na. I really need this job. Could you guys harmonize right now?
除了我们对彼此的喜爱之外，我并不了解桑迪。我不知道我们在音乐、歌剧以及……上竟然有那么多共同点。不，我们开始了。五，六，七，八。啦，啦，啦，啦。我真的很需要这份工作。你们现在能来个和声吗？
No. Yes, let's try it. I'll bet you could. No. Now, how do you do that? Somebody starts to know. I can't flop sweat right now, you guys. I have to finish this press tour.
不能。可以，我们试试吧。我敢打赌你可以。不能。现在，你们是怎么做到的？有人开始……我知道。我现在可不能紧张得出虚汗，伙计们。我还得完成这次宣传巡演呢。
I can't, my pores can't open and ooze. And just mess up the 12 hours of hair and makeup that went into this day. Harmonizing would make you sweat. It would make me sweat. Yeah, any kind of singing. See, you guys have radio voices. I have a not a voice for radio.
我不能，我的毛孔不能打开往外渗汗。然后把为今天精心准备了12个小时的头发和妆容全弄毁了。和声会让你流汗。这会让我流汗。是的，任何形式的唱歌。你看，你们都有广播员的嗓音。我可没有一副适合做广播的嗓音。
We have radio faces is what we got. Now, Sandy, sadly, there's a classic question an interviewer probably would ask, probably something like Sean would ask, but I'm going to ask a different way. The common question would be, what have you done that you would like to do? My question is, what have you done
我们有适合上镜的脸，这就是我们的情况。现在，桑迪，悲哀的是，采访者通常会问一个经典问题，可能类似于肖恩会问的那种，但我打算换个方式问。常见的问题会是，你做过什么事是你还想去做的？我的问题是，你做过什么事
because you don't want to do it and that's never going to change. You're not ever, like for me, it would be Shakespeare. I'd be way too scared to do that. I couldn't do it. I couldn't do it. So what about it for you? Is it singing and dancing?
是因为你根本不想做而且永远也不会改变的？你永远不会，就像对 R 来说，那会是莎士比亚。我太害怕了，做不到那个。我做不到。我做不到。所以对你来说是什么？是唱歌和跳舞吗？
Singing, dancing, dancing, yes. Singing, no. That's so crazy. It's such a big part of your life. I bet you can sing and you're being. I'm telling you, I can carry a tune. I can hum any. I just remember my dad saying,
唱歌，跳舞，跳舞，是的。唱歌，不。这太疯狂了。唱歌明明是你生活中的很大一部分。我敢打赌你会唱歌，而且你只是在……我告诉你，我能把调子唱准。我可以哼唱任何……我只记得我爸爸说过，
cause he was such an incredible teacher. He would travel between New York and DC and he'd taught people at the Met and he would fix voices and teach them from the diaphragm and he'll voices and he says, you can have a five octave range. It doesn't matter if you cannot express yourself through song.
因为他是一位了不起的老师。他经常往返于纽约和华盛顿之间，他在大都会歌剧院教过学生，他会帮人矫正嗓音，教他们如何用横膈膜发声并治疗嗓音，他说，你可以拥有五个八度的音域。如果你不能通过歌剧表达自己，那也无济于事。
People can sound like a car backed over them and have more to say with their voice. I can't. So your dad talked about music. He was a musician, very talented. Like to talk about all that kind of, I mean, imagine having a father, or just having a father who was around,
有些人听起来就像被车从身上轧过去一样，但他们的声音却能表达更多内容。我不能。所以你爸爸经常谈论音乐。他是个音乐家，非常才华横溢。喜欢谈论所有这些，我的意思是，想象一下有一个父亲，或者仅仅是有一个陪伴在身边的父亲，
but having one who also could talk about music, something that you're really interested in. Well, my mother and my mother had a voice like Maria Callas. My mother sounded like Maria Callas. She had the most exquisite voice in the power behind her stillness. And she was exquisite. It was a king's art.
但他同时还能跟你谈论音乐，谈论你真正感兴趣的事情。嗯，我母亲，我母亲的嗓音就像玛丽亚·卡拉斯。我母亲听起来就像玛丽亚·卡拉斯。她拥有最精致的嗓音，在她的沉静背后蕴含着巨大的力量。而且她非常精致。那是一门精湛的艺术。
It's a king's art. Sean, are you crying right now? Sorry. A little bit on the inside. Sean, so Sandy, what you don't know? Sean's father drove away from him doing about 130 in a domestic six back in the passenger seat. Right?
这是一门精湛的艺术。肖恩，你现在在哭吗？抱歉。内心有点小感动。肖恩，那么桑迪，你不知道的是？肖恩的父亲开着一辆道奇六缸车，副驾驶座上坐着他，以大约130英里的时速从他身边疾驰而去。对吧？
Really? Yeah, it was five years old. No, wait, Sandy, I'm gonna sing something you're gonna say. I'm really sad right now. I'm gonna sing something you're gonna say in the name of the opera, ready? Okay. Quand du min vo, quand du min vo,
真的吗？是的，当时我五岁。不，等等，桑迪，我要唱一段你会说……我现在真的很伤心。我要用歌剧的方式唱一段你会说的，准备好了吗？好的。Quand du min vo, quand du min vo,
quand du min vo, solet, la perra, la ria. Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun. I don't know the name, but I know the two. Well, your mom had to have sang that. Well, not like, but nice voice, Sean. I know, it's beautiful. I know, Sean, it's really good. Really nice.
quand du min vo, solet, la perra, la ria. 噔，噔，噔，噔，噔，噔，噔。我不知道名字，但我知道这个调子。嗯，你妈妈肯定唱过那个。嗯，虽然不像，但嗓音很好听，肖恩。我知道，这很美。我知道，肖恩，这真的很棒。真的很不错。
Sean, do you do parties? I'm so glad. Here's the sad part. Yes. Now, here's another one. And both this goes for Sean and or Sandy. Who said this great quote? You ready?
肖恩，你接派对演出吗？我太高兴了。悲伤的部分来了。是的。现在，还有另一个。这既适用于肖恩，也适用于桑迪。是谁说了这句名言？准备好了吗？
I like a show to unfold and keep presenting itself, surprising you. Jason Bateman? No, don't you dare. No, Sean. Wait, say it again. I like a show to unfold and keep presenting itself, surprising you.
我喜欢一场演出缓缓展开，不断呈现出新意，给你带来惊喜。贾森·贝特曼？不，你敢。不，肖恩。等等，再说一遍。我喜欢一场演出缓缓展开，不断呈现出新意，给你带来惊喜。
Sean said this. David Blaine. Tommy Toon. So look. Oh. We always told my sister that was really her father. My mother had an affair with Tommy Toon. Cause she was so tall.
肖恩说的这话。大卫·布莱恩。汤米·通。所以你看。哦。我们总是跟我妹妹说那其实是她的亲生父亲。我母亲跟汤米·通有染。因为她太高了。
So you didn't feel any pressure or obligation to try singing? No. My dad and mom taught in the house at first before they had their studios. And my dad used to bring me down as a kid and like hit a high C and I would belt it out and go back upstairs. But I think when your parents have such a rigorous
所以你没有感到任何尝试唱歌的压力或义务吗？没有。我爸爸妈妈一开始在家里教课，在他们有自己的工作室之前。我爸爸小时候经常把我带到楼下，让我唱一个高音 C，然后我大声唱出来，就又回楼上去了。但我觉得当你的父母有如此严格的
artistry like they did, the practicing, everything that sounds came out of our basement in the neighborhood kids thought we were insane. I was, it was shame. My mother was a hottie and she had all these and then she would sing opera. And it was just shame and embarrassment for me. I wanted to know.
艺术追求时，就像他们那样，练习，从我们地下室传出的各种声音，让邻居家的孩子们觉得我们疯了。我当时感到羞耻。我母亲是个辣妈，她有所有这些，然后她会唱歌剧。这对我来说简直是耻辱和尴尬。我想知道。
She does sound hot. She, my mother was absolutely gorgeous. And she knew it. Was going into acting a bit of a make good on your part or was there a passion from you? Going into acting was the comedy aspect. Like I lived for Jerry Lewis. I lived for Mrs. O'Eagans.
她听起来确实很火辣。她，我母亲绝对是绝色大美女。而且她自己也知道。进入演艺圈对你来说算是一种弥补，还是出于你自身的激情？进入演艺圈是因为喜剧那一面。比如我为杰瑞·刘易斯而活。我为奥·伊根太太而活。
You know, it's like I lived for any comedy that was. Well, here, here's one of the things. So Jason said it. And so he was saying, you know, you're so, you're so good with people and you're so charismatic, which is all very true. One of the things is, is that you connect with people with audiences.
你知道的，就像我为任何喜剧而活……好吧，这里，这里有一点。所以贾森说过了。然后他说，你知道的，你对人太好了，你非常有魅力，这全都是真的。其中一点就是，你与观众建立了情感连接。
No, it's true. You connect with audiences in this way because, and you're so good and you're so funny because you are very vulnerable on screen, whether you're doing a comedy or you're doing a drama. And which is, which is rare. And you can do any, you're very rare that you can do anything.
不，这是真的。你以这种方式与观众建立连接，因为，而且你这么优秀，又这么有趣，因为你在银幕上非常脆弱，无论是演喜剧还是演正剧。而且这，这是很少见的。而且你可以演任何角色，能做到这一点非常罕见。
So now, so as I say that, I'm thinking like, well, you've done so many great comedies, you've done action, you've done dramas, you've won Academy Awards, you've won everything. What is it in sort of the opposite of what Jason was asking? Well, not what are you scared of. What is that thing that's kind of out there for you? What's your 100 foot wave?
所以现在，当我这么说的时候，我想，好吧，你演过那么多伟大的喜剧，你演过动作片，演过正剧，你拿过奥斯卡奖，你赢得了一切。那么，跟贾森刚才问的相反的那个是什么？好吧，不是你害怕什么。对你来说，那个遥不可及的目标是什么？什么是你的百尺巨浪？
What's the thing that you're chasing? My kids. Yeah. I just wanna not be anywhere that takes me away from seeing they're growing. I really had on this last thing that I did, I just said something in my head, I was like, I feel like this is the last one for a while.
你一直在追逐的是什么？我的孩子们。是的。我只是不想去任何让我无法看着他们长大的地方。我真的在我做的最后这件事情上，我在心里对自己说，我当时觉得，我觉得这是接下来好长一段时间里的最后一部了。
Wow. And I was like, because all I wanna do is just watch them become, and it's happening right now. And I'm sure the pandemic has something to do with that. Everything is so shut down and fear-based. And I just literally, I've had the luck of the draw and that I've been at the right place at the right time. I have a really strong work ethic that I know I have.
哇。我说是因为我只想看着他们成长，而这一切正在发生。我确信大流行病与此有很大关系。一切都关闭了，充满了恐惧。我真的，我运气好，总是在对的时间出现在对的地方。我有着非常强烈的工作伦理，我知道我有。
And the rest of it is luck and timing. And I just don't wanna be anywhere that I go, I just wish I was with my kids wherever they need to go right now. Not in a helicoptery thing, but I'm lucky in that I can pay my bills. I've saved, I love my real estate. I love architecture.
剩下的就是运气和时机了。我只是不想去任何地方让我觉得，我只希望无论我的孩子们现在需要去哪里，我都陪伴在他们身边。不是那种直升机式父母的做法，但我很幸运，我能付清账单。我存了钱，我喜欢我的房地产。我喜欢建筑。
I've always planned to have the rug pulled out, so I'm fine. I just wanna watch them grow up and I don't- I feel the same way. Every job now I look at, I look at, the first thing I think is, is this worth taking, even if it's in town, is this job worth taking in terms of hours
我一直做好准备迎接生活给我的打击，所以我很好。我只想看着他们长大，我不想——我也这么觉得。现在我看的每一份工作，我看的，我首先想到的事情是，这值得接吗，即使是在镇上，这份工作就我将要花出的时间来说值得接吗，
that I'm gonna spend, late nights, whatever it is, or missing early mornings, is it gonna be worth it being away from my kids for this? And the answer is always yes. It's always yes. I'm sure you would say, because Louie is now what? 11. 11, 15.
深夜加班，无论是什么，或者错过了清晨的陪伴，为了这个而离开我的孩子们，值得吗？而答案总是肯定的。总是肯定的。我敢肯定你会这么说，因为路易现在多大了？11岁。11岁，15岁。
He's 11 going on 12th in December. God, he seems older. I know, he's wise, he's a wise- And Lila is nine? Eight going on nine. Okay, so, well, I'm super close on that. For me, that's real close. That's bullseye.
他11岁，12岁差一点，12月就到了。天哪，他看起来比实际年龄大。我知道，他很成熟，他是个成熟的——莉拉9岁？8岁快9岁了。好吧，嗯，我猜得非常接近。对我来说，那真的很接近。简直正中红心。
Amanda's gonna lose it when she hears this. She's so high. Don't tell Amanda I missed it. Now- I've got her, she's on speaker. I'm sure you'll say that every age has been, but what do you like most about this age that they're going through now?
阿曼达听到这个要疯了。她太兴奋了。别告诉阿曼达我错过了。现在——我连着她呢，她正在免提通话上。我确信你会说每个年龄段都有各自的特点，但他们现在经历的这个年龄，你最喜欢什么？
Because for me, I feel like you can find out, because there's so much better with language and feelings, you can find out much more accurately what's going on inside of them than when they're obviously two or three years old. Yeah, yeah. Do you love that part of it? Or do you prefer the sort of the bottle and the pacifier
因为对我觉得，你能发现，因为他们对语言和情感的掌握好太多了，你能更准确地查明他们内心深处在想什么，而不像他们显然只有两三岁的时候那样。是的，是的。你喜欢那一部分吗？还是你更喜欢那种奶瓶、安抚奶嘴
and the diapers and- No, no, no, no, no. I mean, that to me was amazing. I wish now I could go back and have a moment knowing now what I know with them in that stage. So it wasn't, cause I was in a state of panic. I just, I felt like I had so much fear at that time that I missed out on the sweetness of that.
和尿布的阶段——不，不，不，不，不。我的意思是，对我来说那太棒了。我希望现在能回去，带着我现在对他们的了解，重新经历他们在那个阶段的某一刻。所以并不是，因为我当时处于恐慌状态。我只是，我当时觉得有太多的恐惧，以至于我错过了那种甜蜜。
Fear of doing the wrong thing as a mom? Sure, and there was just a lot of stuff going on in my life at that time. And that just, I was running and I was in protection mode, and I just felt like the world was coming in and I just wanted to protect them. And I felt guilt that it was coming in on them. And now that I look back, I go, why are we using worried?
害怕作为一个母亲做错事？当然，而且我当时的生活中有很多事情正在发生。这只是，我在奔跑，我在进入保护模式，我只是觉得外界正在压迫进来，我只想保护他们。而且我感到内疚，因为这种压力正在波及他们。现在回想起来，我在想，我们当时为什么要担心呢？
But it's, you know, 2020. But I love where they are now in the sense that Louis is like a 78 year old philosopher in an 11 year old's body who can talk to you philosophically and empathetically about life on a junior level of high school. Just put just, he says profoundly kind and evolved things. Yet he's obsessed with Naruto and Spider-Man
但你知道，事后诸葛亮嘛。但我喜欢他们现在的状态，路易就像是一个11岁身体里的78岁哲学家，他能用高中初级水平的语言，对生活进行哲学和同理心层面的交流。他只是说出非常深刻、善良且成熟的话。然而他又痴迷于《火影忍者》和蜘蛛侠的
in the Spider-Verse. He's appropriately balanced and jumped. But that's the, we're passing in Jago. That was pre-pandemic when you were at the house through the charcuterie. He's not moved on to it. Jason's like an 11 year old intellect in a 78 year old body.
《平行宇宙》。他有着恰到好处的平衡并充满活力。但那就是，我们在路过 Jago。那是大流行病前你在屋里吃冷盘的时候。他并没有放过这个。贾森就像是一个78岁身体里的11岁智者。
So it's kind of like, you just gotta spend some time with your son because I mean it's- Sandra, Sandy. Yes. So I just, a quick question. You mentioned that, you know, you said Jason, you know that I don't like to go out and stuff like that, that I understand
所以这有点像，你只需要花点时间陪陪你的儿子，因为我的意思是——桑德拉，桑迪。是的。所以，我只想问个简单的问题。你提到过，你知道的，你对贾森说你知道我不喜欢出门之类的话，我完全理解
just from a human standpoint. Nevermind being as, you know, gigantically famous public person like you are. You don't say gigantic to a woman. Sorry. Like Marvin Short. But do you ever just miss going to the grocery store just like, you know, going-
仅仅从人的角度来看。更不用说作为一个像你这样拥有巨大名气的公众人物了。你不能对一个女人说“巨大”。抱歉。就像马文·肖特一样。但你有没有偶尔会想念去杂货店买东西，就像，你知道的，去——
And I do that in places where it's not LA. Like I love roaming up and down the aisles of a grocery store and buying a massive amount of things and you go, I'm going to try this. I'm going to use this for this. And then you have like 17 jarred items that you'll never touch. But you go, but one day if I should need it,
而我在不是洛杉矶的地方就会这样做。比如我喜欢在杂货店的过道里转来转去，买一大堆东西，然后你会想，我要试试这个。我要用这个来做这个。然后你就会有大约17个你永远不会碰的罐装物品。但你会想，但万一有一天我需要它的话，
those campers are right there. Right. But you're a home body. I'm just a home. I love being outside. I'm not a shut-in. I love being outside. I love hiking.
那些罐头就在那儿。没错。但你是个居家的人。我只是个居家的人。我喜欢在室外。我不是一个家里蹲。我喜欢在室外。我喜欢徒步。
I love being- You are great about going out. You call yourself somebody who's staying at home all the time, but you're great about going out for somebody as high profile as you. You keep telling her what she is and she keeps telling me- Wait, guys, stop telling me who I should be. I get the sense that, let me finish.
我喜欢——你很擅长出门。你自称是个总是待在家里的人，但对于像你这样备受瞩目的人来说，你其实很擅长出门。你一直在告诉她她是什么样的人，而她一直在告诉——等等，伙计们，别再告诉我我应该成为什么样的人了。我觉得，让我说完。
I get the sense that you're great at going out. But think about when we've gone out. Yes. What has been the catalyst to go out for us when we go out? The kids, every single time. But the way that you go out, you're not always looking over your shoulder worried about,
我觉得你很擅长出门。但想想我们一起出门的时候。是的。我们每次出门的催化剂是什么？孩子们，每一次都是。但你出门的方式，你不会总是战战兢兢地担心，
you're comfortable being out and about. Yeah, totally, totally, totally. Yes, I just, I'm comfortable in normal settings. I'm not comfortable when you're on a red carpet or when you are- Oh, right, right. When I can talk to people, I love it because I learned something.
你很享受外出闲逛。是的，完全，完全，完全。是的，我只是，我在正常的环境中很自在。当你在红毯上或者当你在——哦，对，对。当我能和人们交谈时，我喜欢，因为我能学到东西。
I can be myself. It's my brain. I'm comfortable with my brain. But it's a weird, I was just showing, you're looking over your shoulder, keep going, is the paparazzi here yet? Are they here yet? But you were like, because he had called them.
我能做我自己。这是我的大脑。我对我的大脑感到自在。但这很奇怪，我刚才在展现，你一直在回头看，继续走，狗仔队来了没有？他们来了吗？但你就像是，因为他之前给他们打过电话。
And then he just called you. I mean, that's what you do. You call them when you're at the post office looking your worst. You do that. Are they here? They're just like us. I was on vacation in Paris once,
然后他刚刚给你打了电话。我的意思是，这就是你干的。你在邮局看起来最糟糕的时候给他们打电话。你就是这么干的。他们来了吗？他们就像我们一样。我有一次在巴黎度假，
the only time I've ever been in Paris. And I was staying at this fancy hotel and the Rolling Stones were staying at the same time. And every day there was a barricade of thousands of people across the street. And just as I exited the hotel, I turned to my friends and I'd go, oh, I'm so sorry. And I'd open the door and I'd wave to everybody.
那是我唯一一次去巴黎。我住在一个豪华酒店里，滚石乐队当时也住在那里。每天街对面都有成千上万人的路障。就在我走出酒店时，我转身对我的朋友们说，哦，非常抱歉。然后我打开门，向所有人挥手。
And one flash would go off. It would just go blink. And they've used that photo over and over again. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. Now let's get to Unforgivable right now. This thing looks, can we say badass on the radio? If you say it like, it looks badass.
结果只有一个闪光灯亮了一下。就闪了一下。他们把那张照片用了一遍又一遍。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。现在让我们来谈谈《不可饶恕》。这东西看起来，我们在广播里能说“牛逼（badass）”吗？如果你这样说的话，它看起来很牛逼。
It looks badass. It looks badass. It will, will for the win. Now, you didn't waste a lot of time in wardrobe fittings and hair and makeup tests. Now, would that, that was a relief. You know, she plays a, she plays an ex-con guys. She's coming out of jail and she doesn't care
看起来很牛逼。看起来很牛逼。威尔，为了胜利。好了，你在服装试穿、发型和妆容测试上没有浪费太多时间。那，那算是一种解脱吧。你知道，她演的是一个，她演的是一个前囚犯，伙计们。她刚从监狱出来，根本不在乎
about the hair and the makeup and the clothes. She doesn't give a shit. That's how the, Ruth Slater, she doesn't give a shit. In a world. This Christmas, Sandy Bullock doesn't give a shit. Right? Now, you don't, do you, you do care a lot or a little about the, about, about the fact that there's a lot.
发型、妆容和衣服。她根本不在乎。露丝·斯莱特就是这样，她根本不在乎。在这个世界里。这个圣诞节，桑迪·布洛克根本不在乎。对吧？现在，你不在乎，你是在乎很多还是很少，关于，关于有很多的事情——
I need to listen. Sorry. Sorry. The whole, the whole glam, the, the unfortunate necessary glam side of, of the female side of this business, which I think is dog shit. Of course you care when you're on a red carpet and you look like shit.
我需要听。抱歉。抱歉。整个，整个光鲜亮丽的一面，这个行业女性这一面不幸且必要的浮华，我觉得那就是狗屎。当然当你走在红毯上却看起来像坨屎的时候你在乎。
It's like. But if you have to do that every day for your part. I couldn't. I couldn't. I couldn't. That's what I loved about, what I loved about. That's what I loved. Just sound it out.
就像是。但如果你每天都要为你的角色做那种事。我做不到。我做不到。我做不到。这就是我喜欢，我喜欢的地方。只要把它念出来。
About what I loved about what I loved. Do you get it? Yeah. That sounds like it. I love physical comedy. None of it is beautiful. None of it required beauty. It like, it translates all.
关于我喜欢什么，关于我喜欢什么。你懂了吗？是的。听起来是这样。我喜欢肢体喜剧。没有什么是唯美的。没有什么是需要美感的。它就像是，能传达一切。
My mother was German, had no sense of humor. And then one day. Speak to that, Sean. She's looking at you. How many doesn't require beauty? Go ahead, Sean. But it doesn't. It doesn't require you to be insanely attractive.
我母亲是个德国人，一点幽默感都没有。然后有一天。谈谈这个吧，肖恩。她在看着你。怎么不需要美感？说吧，肖恩。但这确实不需要。它不需要你美得惊天动地。
And as long as you are able to make an ass of yourself. And my mother was the hardest person to make laugh. And but if I got injured, she thought it was hysterical, she's German. So I realized that physical comedy was one way of making everyone around me comfortable because I automatically look like the ass and they couldn't make me feel like an ass
只要你能让自己出丑。而我母亲是最难逗笑的人。但如果我受伤了，她觉得这太滑稽了，她是德国人。所以我意识到肢体喜剧是让周围每个人都感到舒服的一种方式，因为我自动看起来就像个笨蛋，而他们无法让我觉得自己像个笨蛋，
because I already did it first. It was not very surprising considering that the Germans are the people who invented a word for taking pleasure in other people's. Schadenfreude. Yeah. So, but this film, but the unforgivable December 10th. Yes, December 10th on Netflix.
因为我已经抢先一步这么做了。这其实一点也不让人意外，考虑到德国人是一个发明了一个词来形容从别人的……幸灾乐祸（Schadenfreude）。是的。所以，这部电影，但《不可饶恕》12月10日。是的，12月10日在Netflix上线。
Is not a comedy. Make no mistake, right? But you're saying like a comedy. This Christmas, Sandra Fuller could give two fucks. So like a comedy, you need not worry about all the glam in this. So like a comedy, you need not worry about all the glam in this because it's a badass drama. Yes?
这不是喜剧。毫无疑问，对吧？但你的意思是就像喜剧一样。这个圣诞节，桑德拉·布洛克才不在乎呢。所以就像喜剧一样，你不需要担心这里面所有的光鲜亮丽，因为这是一部硬核正剧。对吗？
Yeah, it's a family drama, but it's also mixed in sort of a murder. I mean, look, I look at it, I go, I like to entertain. So I don't want to find a subject matter that I feel I need to hit people over the head with. I want something that people go, what the fuck just happened here? Why did she do that?
是的，这是一部家庭正剧，但其中也夹杂着一些谋杀案。我的意思是，你看，我看着它，我会想，我喜欢娱乐大众。所以我不想找一个让我觉得必须对观众说教的题材。我想要那种让人看完会说，这到底刚发生了什么？她为什么要这么做？
What kind of person is this? And within that is a story of just, does this woman deserve forgiveness and redemption? Some people say no. And then it's just, I just love the combination of the two. I love that you go, okay, what does someone who's eating themselves alive from the inside out look like?
这到底是怎样一个人？而在其中穿插的是这样一个故事，这个女人值得被原谅和救赎吗？有些人会说不。然后这就是，我只是喜欢这两者的结合。我喜欢那种让你觉得，好吧，一个被内心折磨得生不如死的人是什么样子的？
How do we get there? So you just want to entertain and make people feel something, you know? What about the concept of like Bird Box? Was that the last Netflix film that you did? Bird Box wasn't originally at Netflix. It was at Universal where Stuber was at that time. And that's what it was going to be.
我们该如何达到那种状态？所以你只是想娱乐大众，让人们感受到某些东西，你知道的？那像《蒙上你的眼》这个概念呢？那是你在Netflix拍的最后一部电影吗？《蒙上你的眼》最初并不是在Netflix拍的。它在环球影业，斯图伯当时就在那里。本来就是那样的。
And then he moved. And Scott said, let's drag it over here. And he moved to Netflix and he said, what do you think? And I went, I like trying new things. I like that, I mean, look, as a woman, I'm just surprised I'm still working and it's a nice place to be. But I like the idea of it working at Netflix
然后他跳槽了。斯科特说，把它弄到这边来吧。然后他跳槽到了Netflix，他说，你觉得怎么样？我说，我喜欢尝试新事物。我喜欢，我的意思是，作为一个女人，我只是惊讶自己还在工作，这是一个很好的状态。但我喜欢它在Netflix运作的想法，
because the boys got to do it. The girls hadn't done it yet. Do you feel that thing you just touched on it? You're a woman and you're happy to be still working. Do you feel that thing of like there's less and less roles for women, for you? No, I feel there's more and more and more. Good, that's great.
因为男孩们已经拍过了。女孩们还没拍过。你感觉到你刚才触及的那种东西了吗？你是一个女性，而且你很高兴能继续工作。你是否觉得女性的角色越来越少，对你来说也是这样？不，我觉得越来越多，越来越多了。很好，那太棒了。
Because of streaming, because of everything out there. And look, I'd always planned for the rug to be pulled out much earlier on. That's why my first love, which is restoration and real estate and all that was where my money went. Every penny went into there to build that for the kids if they ever want to take it over. And I had something to fall back on that.
因为流媒体，因为外面的这一切。而且看吧，我一直都做好了随时被淘汰的心理准备。这就是为什么我的第一爱好，也就是房屋修复和房地产等等，成了我金钱的去向。每一分钱都投进去了，为孩子们建起这些，如果他们以后想接手的话。我也有了可以退而求其次的东西，
I loved just as much, if not more, at times. So I didn't want to be left without my creative juices being able to be used. And I'm just surprised that I'm like, okay, this must be my last one. Wait, it's not. So if you were not, well, if they kicked you out of the business tomorrow,
我同样热爱它，甚至有时爱得更深。所以我不想失去能够运用自己创造力的机会。而我只是惊讶于自己会想，好吧，这一定是我最后一部了。等等，并不是。所以如果你不是，好吧，如果明天他们把你踢出这个行业，
would you be an interior designer, an architect, or a realtor? Restorer, or restore, and I like finding properties, finding out what the story is, getting it back to the vibe that I feel it wants to be and finding its use and purpose. All the places that I have are used and it's just, I get to still have the thing
你会成为一名室内设计师、建筑师，还是房地产经纪人？修复师，或者进行修复，我喜欢寻找房产，弄清楚它的故事，让它恢复到我感觉它应该有的氛围，并找到它的用途和目的。我所有的房产都有用途，而且我还能拥有我所热爱的
that I love and spent two and a half years getting to the place that it should be or should have been. So it's not a redo, it's a restore, mostly. Pretty much, pretty much, yeah. I love that. I love that. That's pretty cool.
并花了两两年半时间让它达到应有状态的事物。所以这不是重新装修，主要是一个修复过程。差不多，差不多，是的。我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个。这太酷了。
And you'll rent these? Mm-hmm. Yeah. I love it. Or lease, lease. What's the difference between a rent and a lease? Well, it depends on what they are. Some are homes, some are buildings,
你会把这些租出去吗？嗯哼。是的。我喜欢。或者租赁，出租。租（rent）和租赁（lease）有什么区别？嗯，这取决于它们是什么。有些是住宅，有些是建筑，
some are, you know, it's, I just love the history of architecture that in our country, I think we're so quick to take away. And I think the thing about Europe is you can walk around and you feel the history. I think that's why I love New Orleans so much. I just watched a documentary on PBS about Paul Williams. Oh my gosh.
有些是，你知道的，我只是热爱我们国家的建筑历史，我觉得我们太急于将它们拆除了。而我认为欧洲好的一点是，你可以四处走走，感受到那段历史。我想这也是我为什么那么喜欢新奥尔良的原因。我刚刚在PBS上看了关于保罗·威廉姆斯的纪录片。哦，天哪。
I looked for Paul Williams' home for so long when it was just me and Lou, and I said, how amazing would it be if the home that I find in LA when I was moving from Austin would have been a Paul Williams' home? Like, you know, he used to draw the plans upside down because his clients who were white and he was not,
我找保罗·威廉姆斯的房子找了很久，当只有我和路易的时候，我心想，如果我从奥斯汀搬到洛杉矶时找到的房子是保罗·威廉姆斯的房子，那该有多神奇？就像，你知道的，他以前总是倒着画图纸，因为他的客户是白人而他不是，
he felt they wouldn't want to sit next to him, so he learned how to draw his plans upside down. I know, it's fascinating. It's incredible. And then he went into songwriting and did some of the acting stuff. And what about his cameo in Cannonball Run with Havocorn?
他觉得他们可能不想坐在他旁边，所以他学会了倒着画图纸。我知道，这太迷人了。这太不可思议了。然后他开始写歌，还演了一些电影。那他在《炮弹飞车》里跟哈维·科恩的客串呢？
Short people, obviously. Short people got, you know, is that noise? You wore a lot of hats. They got a little bitty hat. Did any of that strike a chord there, Jason, as I'm singing Havocorn Baby? Yes, oh, that's my father-in-law. That's your father-in-law.
矮个子，显而易见。矮个子有，你知道的，那是那个声音吗？你戴了很多帽子。他们有一顶小小的帽子。贾森，当我唱着哈维·科恩宝贝时，这有没有触动你的心弦？是的，哦，那是我的岳父。那是你的岳父。
And he's, you know, I gotta get him on the show. God damn it. You haven't had him on the show? Who's your father-in-law? Tell, say who it is. His name is Paul Anka. And he's a pillar of the music industry. Will, I'm gonna explain it all to you after this episode.
而且他是，你知道的，我得让他上节目。真该死。你还没让他上过节目？谁是你的岳父？说出来，告诉大家是谁。他的名字叫保罗·安卡。他是音乐行业的顶梁柱。威尔，在这期节目之后我会向你全部解释清楚的。
He's Canadian, I know exactly who he is. I wanna say, you know, when you said you only do projects that keep you close to your family, which I totally admire and totally get, do they ever come visit and hang out with you? And do they, do they get excited about it? Are they like, this looks boring? Louis gets really excited about craft service.
他是加拿大人，我完全知道他是谁。我想说，你知道的，当你谈到你只接能让你离家人近一点的项目时，我完全钦佩也完全理解，他们会经常来探班和你一起玩吗？他们，他们会对这个感到兴奋吗？还是会觉得，这看起来好无聊？路易对剧组餐饮服务非常兴奋。
But since it's COVID hit, there is no craft service. So he's absolutely disinterested in anything that I have to do. Lila, on the other hand, is going to no doubt either be president of the United States or be in the entertainment industry. She is. Wow, she's a force.
但自从新冠疫情爆发后，就没有剧组餐饮了。所以他对我要做的事情完全不感兴趣。另一方面，莉拉毫无疑问以后要么会成为美国总统，要么会进入娱乐产业。她就是这样。哇，她很有魄力。
She's sharp, she's such a powerhouse. So like what, I remember thinking, my kids will never be in the business. And then I was like, why not? Wait, I told her, I said, wait till you're 18. I want you to be baked. I don't want you to be a child. But I said, after you turn 18,
她很敏锐，简直是个实力派。所以就像什么，我记得当时想，我的孩子们绝对不能进这个行业。然后我想，为什么不呢？等等，我告诉她，我说，等到你18岁再说。我想让你思想成熟。我不想让你当童星。但我说，等你满18岁之后，
this is something that you really want, then absolutely. That's really smart. But I want you to be a kid. I want you to have that. We know what it looks like to be a kid on a set. And it's hard. It's hard, yeah, Jason. Look at me, I'm a mess.
如果这是你真正想要的，那就绝对可以。这真的很聪明。但我希望你当个孩子。我希望你拥有那段经历。我们都知道在片场当孩子是什么样子的。这很难。这很难，是的，贾森。看着我，我简直一团糟。
Talk about it, just talk about it. This incredible maternal instinct that you have, it didn't come from having a shitty upbringing. And so you want to make things right for your kids. It came because you had a great upbringing, yes? And you wanted to keep it going? Well, I always knew that I would be a mom. I always knew.
谈谈这个吧，就聊聊这个。你身上那种不可思议的母性本能，它不是来自于一个糟糕的成长经历。所以你想为你的孩子们把事情做好。它是因为你有着一个美好的成长经历，对吗？并且你想把它延续下去？嗯，我一直都知道我会成为一个妈妈。我一直都知道。
And I think my mother saw it and she kept me under lock and key. And I was like, you know, it's very true. My mother was incredibly strict with me. I was not allowed in a car or at a car date or anything like that to be alone with anyone basically till I was 18. Because you were too horny?
我想我母亲也看出来了，所以她把我锁在家里严加看管。我当时想，你知道的，这真的很真实。我母亲对我的管教极其严格。基本上直到18岁之前，我不被允许坐车或者和任何人单独约会之类的。因为你太饥渴了？
Because she, you know, because I was a horn dog. Oh, what about your sister, not so much? Not so much, because Zina got away with murder. She did everything I didn't do. She snuck out, she did drugs, she tried all that stuff. But she was a brilliant student. But I was, I talked back, I questioned authority. I was, my sister told me later on in life,
因为她，你知道的，因为我曾经是个小色鬼。哦，那你妹妹呢，没那么严？没那么严，因为吉娜逃过一劫。她做了所有我没做的事。她溜出去玩，吸毒，她尝试了所有那些东西。但她是个聪明的学生。而我，我顶嘴，我质疑权威。我，我妹妹后来对我说，
she goes, you just didn't play the game right. You fought back. You should have just been the quiet, studious girl that I was, but I wasn't that way. So my mother thought I was just trouble and I didn't do anything. I did not, didn't even skip school. I did nothing.
她说，你只是没有把游戏玩好。你进行了反抗。你本该像我一样做一个安静、用功的女孩，但我不是那样的人。所以我母亲觉得我只是个麻烦制造者，而我其实什么都没做。我没有，我甚至都没有逃过学。我什么都没做。
So I just came from a very sheltered life. I knew that I wanted kids, I loved kids, but I didn't want them any time now. I like boys too much. I wanted to go through that Rolodex. Let me ask you this. Do you, as far as the business goes and it relates to family,
所以我只是来自一个非常温室般的生活。我知道我想要孩子，我喜欢孩子，但我不想马上就要。我太喜欢男孩了。我想先把那个通讯录翻个遍。让我问你这个。你觉得，就这个行业以及它与家庭的关系而言，
do you feel like, do you want to beat it to the punch and leave while you're ahead? Or do you want to work until you know you can't work any longer? Neither, really. I don't, I always think, I'm literally like, the last one I said, this is probably my last one in a long time, just because that's where I am.
你觉得你想急流勇退，见好就收？还是想一直工作到你知道自己再也干不动为止？其实哪个都不是。我才不，我总是觉得，我字面意思上，上一部我说过的话是，这可能是我好长一段时间里的最后一部了，只是因为我当时就在那个状态。
And look, that could be a flop or it could be amazing. I think it's gonna be great fun, but you don't know and I just, I don't know because I sort of just kind of go with where my joy is at that time. And I was like, what if I take, what if I just don't work for a while and I want to come back and they don't let me in?
而且看吧，那可能会扑街，也可能会大获成功。我觉得这会非常有趣，但你根本不知道，我只是，我不知道，因为我基本上就是随着我当时快乐的地方走。我当时想，如果我接了，如果我有一段时间不工作，然后我想回来，他们却不让我进门了呢？
And they go, so they don't let you in? So what's the deal? Like I don't want this business to be, To define you. To define me or to make me anxious if it isn't there for me anymore. That's what I'm striving for, is to just, Your spot will always be saved for you
他们说，所以他们不让你进？那又怎样？就像我不希望这个行业是——定义你。来定义我，或者如果它不再需要我时让我感到焦虑。这就是我一直在努力争取的，只是——你的位置永远都会为你保留，
because you're not, you're not, You'll give me a spot. You're not a success because you're beautiful. You're not a success because you're funny. You're not a success because of all of those things. So in other words, you're not gonna age out or time out or talent out of anything. On top of all that,
因为你不是，你不是，你会给我留个位置。你的成功不是因为你长得漂亮。你的成功不是因为你搞笑。你的成功不是因为所有这些原因。换句话说，你不会因为年龄增长、时间流逝或才华耗尽而被淘汰。除此之外，
you're also producing a ton of stuff too. And with all your set experience, you'd probably be an incredible director as well. I don't want to direct. I have no desire to direct. No, no, no. I mean, I just want to go home. I just want to go home.
你还在制作大量的东西。凭借你所有的片场经验，你可能也会成为一个杰出的导演。我不想当导演。我一点当导演的欲望都没有。不，不，不。我的意思是，我只想回家。我只想回家。
Producing, I'm there anyway. So the producing I love because it's control. It's like, if it's, I don't want anyone to sink my ship but me. Directing, you are responsible. I don't want to be responsible for anything other than that, which allows me to go home to my family. Right.
至于制片，反正我在那儿。所以我喜欢制片是因为它有掌控感。就像是，如果，我不想让任何人弄沉我的船，除了我自己。至于导演，你要负全责。我不想对除了能让我回家陪伴家人之外的任何事情负责。没错。
I love that. So then you're probably, you're probably one take, two takes, Sandy's got it. No, no, no, no. Do you need a lot of takes? I like to come out of the gate prepared. Cause I don't want to waste time. And you know when the clock is ticking.
我喜欢这样。所以你可能，你可能拍一条就行，拍两条就行，桑迪搞定了。不，不，不，不。你需要拍很多条吗我喜欢做好准备再出场。因为我不想浪费时间。而且你知道时间在流逝。
So I mean, that's where once you learn what production is about, most actors don't. And you go, oh, that's money. Oh, that's time. You come prepared. I have a really strong work ethic, probably cause I'm German. I know how lucky I am.
所以我的意思是，这就是一旦你了解了制片是怎么回事，大多数演员其实并不懂。然后你会想，哦，那是钱。哦，那是时间。你得做好准备过来。我有着非常强烈的工作伦理，可能是因为我是德国人。我知道自己有多幸运。
I don't want to waste people's time. I want to give myself every opportunity within the, within the allotted time, you know, and not have someone go, well, we couldn't get it. Let's move on. And I'm like, I panic. Are you a first take person? With drama, yes.
我不想浪费别人的时间。我希望在分配给我的时间内给自己每一个机会，你知道的，而不是让别人说，嗯，我们没拍出来。我们继续吧。而我会恐慌。你是那种一条过的人吗？拍正剧的话，是的。
With drama, yes. And are you a wait, save it for the closeup with drama? I've learned to do that because once I realized, I was like, wait a minute. What do you mean? We're in a wide. I'm just, I'm, I'm spent. And for Tracy in Wisconsin,
拍正剧的话，是的。那你是不是那种——等等，拍正剧时把精彩的留给特写镜头？我学会了这样做，因为一旦我意识到，我就想，等等。什么意思？我们在拍全景。我只是，我，我已经精疲力竭了。而对于威斯康星州的特蕾西来说，
that means that usually when you shoot a scene, you'll shoot the scene in a wider and then they'll move in and you'll get pieces where you'll cover each actor. And they call that coverage. And Sandy. So when you're... So hang on, I'm just explaining for your sister.
这意味着通常当你拍一场戏时，你会先拍全景，然后他们会推进镜头，你会得到一些切镜头来覆盖每个演员。他们把这叫做分切镜头（coverage）。而桑迪。所以当你在……等一下，我只是在为你妹妹解释。
Sean, I'm talking to your sister. Okay, go ahead, sir. And, and so if, if, if Sandy Bullock is doing a very emotional dramatic scene, Tracy, you, she's got to emote. Okay. Hang on. Hang on.
肖恩，我在跟你妹妹说话。好的，请继续，先生。而且，而且如果，如果桑德拉·布洛克正在拍一场非常感人的正剧戏份，特蕾西，你，她必须得有情绪。好吧。等一下。等一下。
Sorry, hang on. Tracy, Tracy. She's all narcoleptic. She's getting some milk from the fridge. Tracy, right here, right here. She probably is getting milk. Okay. So, and now she's back.
抱歉，等一下。特蕾西，特蕾西。她简直像得了发作性嗜睡症一样。她去冰箱拿牛奶了。特蕾西，就在这儿，就在这儿。她可能真的去拿牛奶了。好吧。然后，现在她回来了。
And so she has to keep that, in order to give that performance she wants to give, she wants to give it in the close-up, which is the, the, the size that they're gonna probably cut you in that a moment, in that moment. So Sandy, I have a question. When you're in England and you're shooting and you don't nail it on the first take,
所以她必须保持那种状态，为了展现出她想给出的表演，她想在特写镜头里展现出来，也就是他们可能会在那个时刻把你剪辑进去的景别。所以桑迪，我有个问题。当你在英国拍摄而且第一条没有达到预期时，
do you go, Bullocks, Bullocks, Crikey, Crikey. No, he was doing your last name. He was trying to sneak it, sneak in. Oh, Bullocks, oh, I get it, I get it. This is the host of the year, Sandy. He is. Will, we'll let him let it go. Okay, we can't.
你去死吧，Bullocks，Bullocks，天哪，天哪。不，他在说你的姓。他想偷渡，偷偷溜进来。哦，Bullocks，哦，我明白了，我明白了。这是年度主持人，桑迪。他是。维尔，我们放过他吧。好吧，我们不能。
The world's all time greatest, no, what is his reward? My favorite moment that he did. He played a little stick for women in film. Years ago, my sister and I were there and he's at the piano. And he was the only one that called it what it was. He goes, whiff. No, right, no, but it was, it was women in film,
世界历史上最伟大的，不，他的回报是什么？我最喜欢他做的一个时刻。他在“女性电影人”活动上弹了一小段吉他。多年前，我和我姐姐都在那儿，他在弹钢琴。他是唯一一个直言不讳的人。他说，whiff。不，对，不，但那是，那是“女性电影人”，
partnerships in entertainment, was the full thing. So women in film, partnerships in entertainment, and I wrote a song to Coldplay and I sang it using different words and I called it whiff of pie. It was brilliant, that's right, whiff of pie. See, he did something for the ladies. That's right, I always do stuff for the ladies,
娱乐界合作伙伴，全称是这样。所以“女性电影人，娱乐界合作伙伴”，我给酷玩乐队写了一首歌，我换了歌词唱了它，我把它叫做“馅饼的气味”（whiff of pie）。这太棒了，没错，馅饼的气味。看，他为女士们做了点事。没错，我总是为女士们做事，
I love the ladies. He's a song and dance man. We've kept Sandy book way too long, she's way too important. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Not even, I've made my way through a pack of these. Oh, the Whoppers. Oh, Whoppers, she likes her candy.
我爱女士们。他是个能歌善舞的人。我们留桑迪聊得太久了，她太重要了。对，对，对。甚至不用，我已经吃完一包这个了。哦，Whoppers（华堡麦芽巧克力球）。哦，Whoppers，她喜欢吃糖。
This is when you know you're in a press junket. Caffeine, green tea, and Whoppers, this is. Sandy, we love you. Thank you so much for saying yes and squeezing us in on this. I love you so, so, so much. You know what, thank you for, I'm so proud of you and your wife is amazing.
这就是你知道自己身处记者招待会的时候。咖啡因、绿茶和Whoppers，就是这样。桑迪，我们爱你。非常感谢你答应并抽出时间接待我们。我太爱太爱太爱你了。你知道吗，谢谢你，我为你和你的妻子感到骄傲，她太棒了。
Amanda, Amanda, Amanda, Amanda Enka. She's birthed him, two of the most extraordinary young women I've had the pleasure of watching grow up. Jason, wait til you meet these kids of yours. Remind me of their names. They're incredible. I'm gonna probably see your daughter tomorrow. Tell her how.
阿曼达，阿曼达，阿曼达，阿曼达·恩卡。她生下了两个我见过的最非凡的年轻女性，看着她们长大是我的荣幸。杰森，等你见到你的这些孩子就知道了。提醒我一下她们的名字。她们太不可思议了。我明天可能会见到你女儿。告诉她……
My house, you know she comes to my house for like, play dates, right? She's in love with Lila. Yeah, well, they're cut from the same cloth. And we're in love with you. Thank you for saying yes. Have a great rest of your day. Thank you guys, thank you, thank you.
我家，你知道她来我家过家家，对吧？她迷恋莱拉。是的，好吧，她们是一丘之貉。我们也很爱你。谢谢你答应来。祝你接下来的一天过得愉快。谢谢你们，谢谢，谢谢。
All right, get your flag back up in front of the camera or slam the laptop close or whatever. Oh, do I have to? Really, what is it? Yeah, let your freak flag fly for sure. Ready? There it is. It was so good to see you guys and I'll feed a zine.
好了，把你的旗子重新升到镜头前，或者把笔记本电脑合上，随便什么都行。哦，我必须这样做吗？真的，那是什么？对，展现出你疯狂的一面吧。准备好了吗？就是这样。很高兴见到你们，我会……
Oh! Bye, Sandy. Look at that. All right. Bye, honey, thank you, love you. Bye, guys. Bye. She's sunlight.
哦！再见，桑迪。看那个。好吧。再见，亲爱的，谢谢，爱妳。再见，伙计们。再见。她就像阳光。
She's sunlight, right? That's a movie star, right? That's a movie star. Yeah. And also simultaneously a very real grounded cool person. Well, that's why she's a star. You know, we should, we book a few of those, I think because the three of us are allergic to the other,
她就像阳光，对吧？那是电影明星，对吧？那是电影明星。是的。而且同时又是一个非常真实、脚踏实地、酷的人。嗯，这就是她为什么是明星的原因。你知道，我们应该，我们预约几个那样的人，因为我们三个对其他类型的……
but we should book the other. We should get a real SOB in here. We should. She's great. I didn't know all that stuff about her background and... Yeah, yeah. Did you know that before, Jason? Before you were...
但我们应该预约另一种。我们应该请一个真正的混蛋（SOB）来这里。我们应该。她太棒了。我不知道她背景的那些事……是的，是的。杰森，你之前知道吗？在你……之前
Wikipedia, no. No. Or the opera singer stuff or any of that. So cool. Oh. Yeah. Or the ages of her kids. Or any of that stuff.
维基百科，不知道。不。还是歌剧演员之类的事。太酷了。哦。对。还是她孩子的年龄。或者诸如此类的任何事。
Yeah. Huh. Listen, I don't, I just, I see the eyes. I see the eyes and the heart. Okay. I just see eyes and heart. Eyes and heart. Eyes and heart.
是啊。哈。听着，我不，我只是，我看到了眼睛。我看到了眼睛和心。好吧。我只看到眼睛和心。眼睛和心。眼睛和心。
That's my name. Eyes and heart's the title. Yeah, yeah, George Eisenhardt. George Eisenhardt. Anyway, more like that, please. She was fabulous. Fantastic. No, she's incredible.
那是我的名字。眼睛和心就是标题。是的，是的，乔治·艾森哈特。乔治·艾森哈特。不管怎样，请多来点这样的。她太棒了。好极了。不，她太不可思议了。
Are you guys thinking about a bye right now? Cause I am. I think we should just say it. You know what, do we have a next, we have a show next week, right? Or do we have a bye? Bye. Bye.
你们现在在考虑休息（bye）吗？因为我是。我想我们应该直接说出来。你知道吗，我们有下一个，我们下周有个节目，对吧？或者我们有个假期（bye）？再见。再见。
A bye week. Bye. Bye. Smart. What. Smart. What. SmartLess is 100% organic
假期周。再见。再见。聪明。什么。聪明。什么。SmartLess是由Rob Armjurf、Bennett Barbicoe和Michael Granteri 100%有机手工制作的
and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbicoe, and Michael Granteri. SmartLess. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts
SmartLess。我们的下一期节目将在两周后发布，你可以在你收听播客的任何地方收听，或者现在就在亚马逊音乐（Amazon Music）上提前收听，或者通过订阅Apple Podcasts上的Wondry Plus提前收听并免广告
or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或Wondry应用。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。